black lives matter mmm facts don't
matter
right now the narrative that is being
set is that the system is inherently
racist white privilege yada yada yada
and when cops see any young black man
they go into Lloyd Christmas mode
to the point where places like black
lives matter leftist websites even mtv
news are pushing this idea that innocent
black men are being shot for no reason
at all
and the purpose of this video is not to
justify nor condemn any of the deaths
that occurred during these police
civilian interactions but to provide you
with the context that MTV News and Vox
and HuffPo refuses to let's just use
this video from MTV News that's being
circulated to start all right the
situation with falando we don't really
know a whole bunch yet that didn't stop
MTV News from putting it in a video and
it seems to be a really horrific
accident and hopefully justice will be
served when the information comes out
but we do know that he wasn't shot for
broken taillights he was shot during an
altercation where he was pulled over
because he matched a description for a
suspect in an armed robbery police were
on high alert for a gun police gets shot
in routine traffic stops all the time
statistically yeah it happens a lot of
the hands of young black men and there
was a miscommunication with falando
reaching for what he claims to be his
wallet or ID and the cop thought was a
gun now that doesn't mean that any of
this is justified or it's a good
situation but to simplify it to shatter
broken taillight is deliberately
misleading clearly Alton sterling wasn't
shot for selling CDs he was shot because
someone called in a report that he was
threatening a homeless man with a gun he
was tased first and he continued to
resist arrest and he had a firearm on
him which I'm guessing was illegal
because this guy had a rap sheet a mile
long including being a registered sex
offender having done time in prison for
violent crimes
this wasn't a routine pat-down this was
an altercation with a longtime felon who
didn't want to go back to the slammer is
it unfortunate yes was he arrested and
shot for selling CDs no only mr. Clark
was not shot for attending a birthday
party he was shot for preventing
paramedics for assisting with an assault
victim he wasn't handcuffed he refused
to show his hands and there is DNA
evidence showing that he reached for a
cop's gun he wasn't there to play
balloon tricks I almost forgot little
tidbits I'm the assault victim that he
was interfering with the police trying
to help it was his girlfriend yeah he
was one who assaulted her what a gem but
by all means please continue with a
narrative that cops are simply out there
hunting down young black men because
attending birthday parties and selling
CDs I hate you what they don't tell you
is Walter Scott tried to grab an officer
stun gun and he did run away from the
police because he didn't want to pay
child support that being said the cop
acted poorly but no justice no peace
wait there's justice he's being charged
with murder this system worked ok
Michael Brown was not shot for stolen
cigarillos what happened at that
convenience store was a robbery not
shoplifting there was use of violent
force he was identified as a suspect in
that robbery he reached for an officer's
gun but hands up don't shoot his hands
weren't up he was punching a cop in the
face and reaching for his gun when that
happens sometimes officers are trained
to shoot are there several points where
this didn't have to escalate of course
but the idea that a racist cop picked
off some gentle giant Michael Brown is
entirely inaccurate as the rest of these
examples Sandra bland traffic violation
to the untrained uneducated eye that
looks terrible
she was murdered for traffic violation
no she was detained and she killed
herself a lot of you want to say it's a
conspiracy no third party autopsy
results revealed that were consistent
with that and there was marijuana in her
system no I'm not saying that all people
smoking joints should go kill themselves
just if you're watching this go get a
snack again court he wasn't killed
because his car broke down this was a
horrible situation with a cop who by the
way was fired after it's important to
note that he was fired for not doing his
job well he thought a car was abandoned
it was 3:15 a.m. dark outside mr. Jones
was there and he did have a legal
firearm but you're a cop
you're looking into what you think is an
abandoned car in the middle of the night
and all of a sudden you're confronted
with an armed subject so the cop was
fired and it seems rightfully so but try
and think about this situation he didn't
go into it shooting a guy because he was
black he probably went into it a little
bit nervous in a bad area of town at a
dark time of the night and he had
stories in the back of his head from all
of his friends in the force who had died
who made a wrong decision guy pulls out
a gun they're dead and someone has to go
explain to their wife and kids why
daddy's never coming home again again he
was fired but let's try and see this as
more than car broke down he was shot
because he was black Freddie
I was not killed for carrying a
switchblade okay first off he fled the
police unprovoked he saw the cops they
looked at him boom the kid bolted and he
happened to have a switchblade on him
again not justifying all the actions but
half of the cops who arrested him were
black and he was brought up on weapons
charges in an area that is notorious for
high crime pretty grand something like
20 criminal cases against him five open
at the time of arrest by the way when he
was high as a kite on opioids and I
think it was pot in this system now that
matters because the argument that he was
killed in a rough ride in a cop car by
the way with half the cops who were
black and he died seven days later in a
trauma ward but the fact that there was
a struggle and he was high as a kite can
certainly lead to one being more likely
to be injured especially considering
that a judge let the driver go does it
mean that mistakes weren't made no does
it mean that this death was warranted no
but he wasn't shot for having a
switchblade Shawn bail for leaving a
bachelor party well he was just enjoying
his night except what actually happened
is he left a club being patrolled by
undercover cops he made a run at the
cops when they identified themselves
openly as cops and the members of his
entourage were known felons dang most
bachelor parties just have male
firefighter strippers female I mean
female Oscar Grant I didn't finish
Fruitvale station because I found it
incredibly boring it appears this is a
case of a cop not doing his job well for
that he was fired so um give me this one
MTV News except Tamir rice wasn't killed
for a SuperSoaker in the park he was
aiming a firearm replica with the orange
tip removed at people in the park his
age was not determinable at the time as
you can see by this video and officers
weren't informed that the gun might have
been fake is it a horrible unfortunate
situation yes but they didn't say hey
you know what would be fun today if we
go kill a black kid for nerf Ramarley
Graham again this is an even more
complicated situation the cops an arc
unit followed him after they thought
that they had spotted a gun in his
waistband and they had some reason to
believe that he just participated in a
drug deal well it turns out they may
have had some reason because he ran from
the cops when they identified themselves
and he tried to flush a bag of weed down
a toilet he ended up being shot when he
didn't have his hands up and allegedly
he reached for something in his
waistband now the cops didn't have a
warrant to be in his apartment so guess
what
I have a problem with those cops and
they should be fired again was this guy
shot solely because he was black or is
this an example of a situation that
escalated and requires context for
people to understand no he wasn't killed
for walking around with a knife at all
he was a gang member a currently active
gang member
they found him after report from a
stabbing victim at large still holding
the knife he continued to hold the knife
and refused to put down the knife even
after being pepper sprayed and shot with
a beanbag gun and then he started
walking toward the cops with the knife
as you can see in this video so yes they
put 20 rounds in him how do you don't
know this knives are incredibly
dangerous much more dangerous than guns
that distance is less than 21 feet we'll
other references up at ladder with
Crider calm people get hurt all the time
officers get maimed all the time by
knives so in this situation the officers
have a decision to make
eliminate the threat who is a currently
active gang member who may or may not
have stabbed someone else who refuses to
drop the knife and is coming toward you
or risk serious bodily harm by an active
knife wielder in an attempt to be more
politically correct
instead they opted to eliminate the
threat so they could go home to their
families what choice would you make see
previous example Katherine Johnson
here's one that I agree with isn't that
great that we can create a video that's
actually truthful to encourage a
dialogue of honest discussion to the
best of my knowledge according to my
research and not gay Jared's research
the cops were acting unbelievably
outside of the law they may have planted
evidence it seems like there was some
shady stuff going on with falsified
reports but here's the beauty the cops
went to prison as they should
would it have been better than a 92 year
old didn't get killed in a botched drug
raid of course but the cops are in
prison John Crawford the third this is
the famous Walmart Beaver Creek guy with
the toy BB gun do we have a video on
this yep okay well let's bring that up
so some shoppers mistook it for a real
gun there are some reports that refused
to comply with officers but look at this
this is nowhere near the hunting section
and he's using the gun to select his
fruit loops this is wildly erratic
behavior I think it's an unfortunate
situation he really shouldn't have been
shot and the cops should probably be
punished but he wasn't just shot because
he picked up a BB gun at the Walmart toy
section is
okay let's shoot him we have an excuse
Kenneth Chamberlain an example of cops
being crappy by the way white people
encounter crappy cops to a medical
device called the police to his home it
seems like you refused to open the door
he had a blood alcohol at which point he
was legally drunk and it's just a crappy
situation all around
seems like bad cops can we find some
common ground can we have a truthful
discussion here Eric garner go back to
my previous podcasts I always maintain
that the cops were unnecessarily rough
with Eric garner but he was resisting
arrests he was big they didn't kill him
the guy had a heart attack because he
was so overweight still the cops should
be prosecuted that cop that was raking
his face into the sidewalk I have a
problem with him that's an abuse of
authority can we find some common ground
or least you have to lie about everyone
else
India patty holding a fake gun that's
not what happened it was 120 a.m. it was
dark
cops were investigating an unrelated
case they saw her getting into an
argument with an unarmed person and she
threatened him with the gun she then
refused to comply with police officers
and was shot as a result unfortunate yes
an example of clear-cut racism no of
course not
noon in her attic is a very vague term
but the cop was black here so yeah
Trayvon Martin for wearing a hoodie Oh
Thank You Geraldo Rivera for your
misspeak making this a meme for all time
no he wasn't killed for wearing a hoodie
George Zimmerman I've said it he's a
jackass not a fan he should have stood
down he didn't have to follow this kid
but when that situation escalates to the
point where the kid is bashing your head
into the concrete here's the deal
whenever you assault somebody that
violently you're forfeiting your right
to live people don't like to hear that
but here's the deal if someone holds me
at knifepoint or gunpoint or assaults me
in the street or sucker punches me you
don't know what the intent is of that
person you don't know if they're simply
trying to impress their friends or if
it's some form of gang initiation or if
they're a crazy person dead set on
killing you you don't know if they want
your watch or they want your life the
second you escalate it to a point that
is violent enough that could kill
somebody whether it's your intent or not
you forfeit your right to live and
that's what happened here tragic yes but
this is not out of the ordinary again
the point of this video is not to
justify all the killings nor is it to
condemn all the killings I think if
we're being honest I've been fair and
pretty reasonable if you don't think so
let me know below the point is that when
it's black lives matter or mtv news
HuffPo
or whatever the organization is that day
when they put out their this idea that
cops in record numbers are simply
killing black people because of a level
of melanin in their skin for benign
activities and no reason at all what
does that do well it makes it okay to
vilify cops it makes it okay to
dehumanize cops and it makes it okay to
treat them sub humanely because think
about this for a second if you genuinely
believe as many of the cop killers out
there right now do that officers are
killing people for simple things like
selling CDs for going to a birthday
party well of course you could justify
it as your duty to kill police officers
and people have my point is that if you
are not honest if you are simply using a
false narrative to try and generate
clicks you then allow somebody to hang
their latest outrage cannon and whoever
subject you deemed to be suitable in
this case lately unfortunately it's been
a lot of innocent police officers right
before the Dallas shootings if you watch
this channel I said hey if it gets to
the point where it's more controversial
to say wait for the facts than it is to
demand the public lynching of officers
we have a problem that video was
released right before the Dallas
shootings I am telling you this right
now if we do not start having an honest
conversation about what is going on you
are going to create an atmosphere that
you can't take back and you will regret
that's the only purpose to this video
hope it's been of use to you next one
we'll have more immature wiener jokes
hey if you like this video subscribe by
clicking my face or go to lighter with
credit calm for sources and references
to all of the statements made on this
video send me angry emails I'll accept
the more you can click one of these
videos next to me ones playing in a bowl
or one of them is a mystery box
oh what's that this is the Internet
could be anything
could be something fantastic could be
something you never seen before good
scar you for life